advert also gets the start and he is
coming off a really nice effort against
the cardinals
he was a tough luck loser in terms of
getting bitten by the home run
late in the game against st louis but
overall he's pitched well this year
jesse winker leads it off in there got
him looking he put himself in a no two
spot winker and bruce jackman
having a chat and on three pitches jesse
winker
is gone one down nobody on the batter
nicholas castellanos he swings the first
pitch and lines one to left
that'll fall at the feet of jack
peterson for a one-out single
and make it a 14-game hit streak for
nick castiano's
and the batter is tyler and naked one
outside
corner and dreckman rings him up red's
hitters haven't been so happy
at least thus far and two down
azalea though throwing bb so far
two outs here's tyler stevenson shot the
opposite way
falling fast and it slips on past ortega
castellanos through second stop sign in
third a slide in the second base
and a hustle bloop double by tyler
stevenson
the reds have two in scoring position
tucker barnhart coming to the plate
it's a high pop fly should be playable
for baez in shallow center the shortstop
will
make the catch and the inning is over
welcome to the show
vladimir gutierrez signed by the reds
out of his native cuba
judy aries is 25 years old now so you
know it's not like he's a young kid
around 19
20 years old making his major league
debut you've got to figure that heart
is pumping right now chuck peterson to
lead it on
breaking ball is lifted high into the
air short left center field winker
coming on he will actually take it in
front of naquin
for out number one and chris bryant the
batter hits one of the air
not to center field naquin will come in
as he moves toward right to make the
catch
two down here in the bottom of the first
inning no score of the batter is javier
bayez
baez lifts up that breaking ball well
out of his own
winker makes the squeeze in three
fly-outs for vladimir gutierrez
his first major beginning of work so the
rare walk
for advert also they've gone 90 straight
batters without a walk and issues the
free pass with one out
and the batter now will be jonathan
india
runner goes and the pitch is slug to
right that's gonna get down
shrock in the hit and run easily has
third perfect timing to ignite schrock
and men at the corners with one out so
the young pitcher now the chance to
help his cause no score in the second
and a swing and a miss struck him out
third strikeout for adbert
also now there are two down but you're
not out of the woods by any means with
jesse
winker standing in and that one drilled
out towards center half on the move
and back and he makes the catch reds
don't score they leave a pair
so a threat again for the reds also has
been pitching
into and then out of trouble kyle farmer
the battle
and this one popped up he's going to get
out of it again
sogar gives way to ortego makes the grab
and that is the inning first time
through the order for vladimir gutierrez
no hits allowed just the one base runner
on the walk
batter is john peterson
to left field winker
sliding did he make the grab he did
jesse winker winker slides into the wall
a sensational catch india at first with
one away no score for thinning the
batter is vladimir gutierrez
he gets that one down india's got second
lob
goes over to first sacrifice complete
you know what you don't ask how you
don't ask why sometimes you're just glad
that it happened
on a day of firsts the big league debut
there's the
first sacrifice for gutierrez in the
show
and it's a big sacrifice because now two
outs you've got one of the best hitters
in baseball
just a base hit to get a run here
swinging a high
fly ball should be playable for ian happ
in center coming in and calling
ian happ is there makes the catch he
slid at the very end
no runs for the reds the cubs have two
on
with one out and the batter is wilson
contreras
they go away and he nips the edge strike
three
the first career big league strikeout
for vladimir gutierrez and it's a big
one with two men aboard
you get out of this inning you can feel
invincible swing swinging a miss
back-to-back case for vladimir gutierrez
vladimir gutierrez has been awfully good
for the reds and his big league debut
at wrigley field today bodie up here and
one drill down to left field line that
one towards the corner
it got out of here a home run for david
bodie
it cut through the wind a voting bomb
and the cubs lead it
wow alfred also has been very good
it'll be tucker barnhart to lead things
off on the inside corner
got him great pitch he ran it back over
the inside edge
that's the old front hip matic special
right six of them now for al's eli
now kyle farmer here's the ground ball
to short fielded by
baez in a running throw to first in time
and that's out number two
two down nobody on mack shrock the
batter center field surprising carrie
happ streaks back it's over his head
into the ivy and truck goes into second
standing as he
hammers a two out double jonathan
indy awaits three two oh
wow so alzalei walks
india on a pitch just off the outside
edge
that is going to be all i believe for
advert alzheimer
the last 11 games not a single earned
run
has been allowed by any member of the
cub bullpen andrew chafin the new man
on the mound and this is a eugenio
suarez
to perform as a pinch hitter swing and a
missed strike three
suarez came up empty and the inning
comes to an end
we're joined by joey votto and joey you
were saying it
you've had a desire to try to do a
little play-by-play
are you are you ready for your big
league play-by-play debut
i can't wait i do this in bed by myself
at night well come on oh yeah that's all
i think about
yeah right all right we'll cry chris
bryant's up there joey take it away
middle slider base hit to left field by
chris bryant man on first
good swing chris he's been working with
his dad for his entire life
and uh we talked about hitting a little
bit at first base and he has
he's very very sharp have your bias into
play
dangerous bat great pitch great throw by
barnhart looks like we've got a double
play right there on a down and away
slider and a throw by barnhart
great throw by barnhart excellent strike
him out throw him out 2-4 with india
covering in second base
another dangerous hitter half can make
this a two-nothing game slider strike
three
all right and that is a great comeback
by hembree after the
inning beginning single so a threat for
the reds first and second and one out it
brings up the number four hitter
tyler stevenson and that one to the
right side sogar
tag throw the first double play and he
gets out of it
and crick kimbrell to take over happy
birthday craig
kimbrell his 33rd reds down to their
last chance
jesse winker at the plate out in front
of the mound kimbrough has it happy
birthday craig kimbrell comes with one
nothing
[Applause]